do you worry that there might be a war
in space
yes let's let's look out into the future
so forget so the interesting thing about
these Rockets right let's not forget
rock is uh do what Rockets do that they
can carry payloads that uh can be
weapons
um do you worry about this
I worry most about space wars as leading
to The Kessler syndrome of of having uh
cascading effect of like a spacecraft
blowing up and then affecting another
spacecraft and that blows up and then
all of a sudden you're trapped and have
this debris Cloud that we can't
you know go we can't go into space
anymore like that's my biggest because
frankly at this point we could
annihilate ourselves with terrestrial
stuff anyway you know what I mean we
don't need space to to end society as we
know it you know what I mean yeah
um but we do we could really and I the
the good thing is I think everyone well
mostly everyone seems to understand this
for the most part that like
we really can't be risking blowing up
stuff in space in low earth orbit
because it could easily like we could
strain ourselves from space assets for
50 years
if oh can you elaborate on that so like
what is the danger of the debris there
that uh could jeopardize yeah so for
instance and I was only a couple years
ago Russia did an anti-satellite test on
a on an orbital there's a we've done
this to the U.S has done this like I'm
not pinning it on them but we kind of
know nowadays like don't do
anti-satellite tests on orbital things
because those things stay in orbit you
know when you blow something up in space
it's not like
you know people think you know when in
in space like oh you throw a something
that's just going to keep going forever
and ever and ever yeah I mean that's in
the in the sense that it's not going to
be slowed down due to you know due to
air resistance it's going to continue to
do that but it's staying in orbit around
the Earth like you just slightly change
the orbit of it around earth when you
throw a ball or something you know
so the scary thing is when you blow up a
satellite
all those pieces of that satellite are
now
millions of bullets in a halo around the
Earth
in a very specific Halo you know so some
things get blown up uh faster you know
in according to its orbit faster so
they'll go a little bit higher
elliptically some things will get slowed
down in that explosion and actually
re-enter some things will go sideways
and change its inclination of that orbit
so you have this debris field but it
more or less becomes a band of like
No-No you know like a big scary
sharp scary bullets that can destroy
another spacecraft and so all of a
sudden especially now starlinking we're
talking about thousands and thousands
and thousands of satellites in space
if all of a sudden one you know a couple
of them crash and and you know blow up
and obviously you have all the shrapnel
going everywhere and then that hits
another satellite that creates shrapnel
you can literally blanket our entire low
earth orbit
and 17 500 mile an hour bullets
you know we're talking that the the
connect the kinetic energy in this is so
hard for people to Fathom because that
you know that's over 10 times faster
than most like rifle bullets and even
like a big 50 cal
is not going to be you know we're still
talking about about 10 percent
that so when you think about the kinetic
energy it's insane so a Fleck of paint
can go through panes of glass
at that velocity you know a little piece
of metal can puncture you know blow
straight through
so like
so our actions that seem small so small
scale military actions
can have uh
can have dire detrimental effects to the
whole Space Program like Global Space
Program oh yeah it can affect everything
and everyone including the like
including satellites oh yeah especially
satellites like that's why I mean the
good and the bad thing is the good thing
is a lot of satellites don't operate in
low earth orbit like a lot of uh the the
ones that we use day to day a lot of
them are in medium earth orbit like the
GPS or their geostationary uh which are
way way out there and because of that
they they won't really ever de-orbit or
like it'll take you know Millennia to
deorbit because you know just because
something's in space doesn't mean it's
there forever especially like in low
earth orbit the atmosphere doesn't just
suddenly stop it's not like you hit the
Carmen line 100 kilometers and also
there's zero atmosphere the atmosphere
just slowly tapers you know you can
experience that yourself as you climb a
mountain you slowly realize there's less
and less air you just keep going and
just because you're in space 200 300
kilometers up there's still Trace
molecules you know there's the
occasional oxygen molecule there's the
occasional nitrogen molecule and so that
is actually dragged so as a spacecraft
in low earth orbit depending on its
altitude will take anywhere from
five years to five months to deorbit you
know or two months or one month like
depending on its orbit or its altitude
we'll have some parasitic drag still and
slowly throughout time slow down which
lowers its orbit which drags it down
more lowers its orbit Etc et cetera
until it reenters so if we end up with
uh some kind of catastrophic event where
the entire low earth orbit is you know
has been inundated and blown up it'll
take months for the first band you know
to clear up it'll take years for
something like Beyond there's charts you
know people have all this stuff
available you shouldn't look it's
terrifying by the way but this is really
the but again the caveat is for the most
part the low earth orbit stuff would
clear up within years so we could get
back to doing some more with it like
starlink stuff would probably be able to
be re and you know we could kind of redo
it and build up from the ground up again
GPS wouldn't be wiped out and our
geostationary satellites wouldn't be
wiped out but the scary thing is we
wouldn't be able to relaunch and replace
new things because we're stuck we're not
going to fly through that debris field
you know
and we avoid that by avoiding military
actions in space and these days like
there's more and more uh requirements
and and legislation and especially
trying to get International
collaboration on having end-of-life
plans for satellites so that satellites
especially those in low earth orbit have
like drag devices to increase them once
they're done they literally pull like
even just a ribbon like a silly little
like you know 40 foot long ribbon will
sit there and it'll slowly it or it can
speed up its re-entry process by months
or years or whatever so we're starting
to see that this is now an importance
there's a a really cool company called
Stoke Aerospace out in Washington is one
of these launch provisor providers
that's really looking not into just
trying to be the next you know SpaceX
launch company they're really seeing
satellite uh bringing stuff down from
space is actually being especially right
now we have all of these hundreds and
thousands of satellites being launched
every year someone at some point is
probably gonna have to do some cleanup
and so they're looking at being one of
those companies to do that